pour être honnête, je
ne crois toujours pas vraiment que cela se
passe en ce moment
brandebourg
j'ai un drone et j'aime le cinéma et tout
ça et j'aime vraiment
tout le sujet tesla donc j'étais comme ou
peut-être que je pourrais le documenter et montrer une
émission comme le  processus de construction à tous les
fans de tesla dans le monde entier afin qu'ils puissent voir oh
ça se passe comme ça c'est rapide
amusant américain toilettes électriques
elon musc la passion de henry ford
quand vous regardez tout ce qu'il
fait, vous voyez qu'il a ça dans son esprit
comme nous avons besoin  pour changer
quelque chose mais il n'en parle pas
il
fait des choses tesla vision
[Musique]
vous deviez donner la réponse et
bien sûr une réponse positive
plus ou moins dans le cadre de la réunion donc il n'y
avait aucune excuse pour dire que
nous vous fournirons la réponse dans
environ une semaine environ maintenant, ils veulent avoir
la réponse sur
place, c'était un défi, mais nous en avons fait
la construction à l'avance,
nous devons être conscients de la situation ou
du risque que ce
type de permis  seront contestés devant les
tribunaux
et nous devons le délivrer de manière à ce qu'il
résiste à un tel défi et c'est
la principale priorité
et c'était un signal d'alarme, nous sommes là
exactement au bon moment
parce que nous voyons que dans  au cours des trois derniers
mois, il y a eu un grand mouvement, en particulier
en allemagne, en particulier en europe,
encore une fois,
nous avons une capacité d'environ un
million de voitures entièrement électriques dans le monde,
nous avançons très très vite
et voyons cela et comparons cela à nos
concurrents,
je pense que nous sommes des organisations bien placées
les gens eux-mêmes euh ils sont confrontés à
un énorme changement
et nous devons leur donner le temps de
s'habituer à la nouvelle situation
est
elon dit que tout le monde devrait s'amuser nous
voulons que cela et ce cacheur vert fassent
partie de tout ce
qu'il veut avoir un  grande fête au démarrage de l'
usine
et j'espère qu'ils pourront aider les gens à
comprendre la mission derrière
et savoir d'accord c'est un petit prix que
nous payons pour une
chose beaucoup plus grande par la suite